2025 is the beginning of a
once-in-a-lifetime perfect storm for
apologetics pmics and evangelism or
putting all of these together in just
the right environment a Revival
apologetics is Defending Your Own
position polemics is attacking an
opposing position evangelism is
spreading the good news a perfect storm
is when you get a rare combination of
events that combine and amplify until
you get some sort of Mega hurricane
you've never seen anything like this
think about the features that have all
lined up for this moment in history
first going back about 15 or 20 years we
finally got open access to Muslims
around the world for 14th centuries
Muslim leaders were able to keep their
people insulated from hearing criticisms
of Islam and from hearing serious
presentations of alternatives to Islam
then suddenly we got open access to any
Muslim with an internet connection
Muslims in Saudi Arabia and Pakistan and
Iran finally started hearing the truth
about Muhammad and about Jesus 14
centuries of Christians couldn't have
dreamed of the opportunities we have
right now second simultaneously we got
open access to their sources if you go
back just a century you could find a
translation of the Quran if you looked
hard enough but if you really wanted to
know what's in the Muslim sources you
were going to have a difficult time
finding it their main sources hadn't
even been translated yet this allowed
Muslim preachers to say pretty much
anything they wanted about Islam and no
one could correct them because no one
knew what's in their sources fast
forward to today and we've got sah
alkari and sah Muslim and Sun Abu da and
anai and jam and sunb Maja and so
on and this allows us to expose the
endless da lies we're the first
generation that has this open access to
their
sources third there's the Avalanche of
apostasy you've heard about the
Avalanche of apostasy the apostasy rates
among young Muslims went from close to
0% in the early 2000s to around 24% by
2020 this sent Muslim leaders into full
panic mode
24% of Muslim youth are leaving Islam
your child about to become apostate 23%
are becoming apostates of Muslims
American Born Muslims our Muslim friends
had no idea how to react to the
Avalanche of apostasy they' never had to
deal with it before so what did they do
well in a panic they replaced all of
their most popular dawa Champs with
total narcissists who responded to all
challenges with threats and insults that
didn't work so they started grasping for
any popular influencer they could bribe
and they ended up clinging out of sheer
desperation to people like Andrew Tate
and sneo and now Lily Jay things have
gotten so bad we couldn't find anyone to
stand up for Muhammad at debate conon I
actually had to defend Muhammad at
debate con 5 this is the state of dawa
in 2025 not looking good it's crumbling
from within and they have no plan B
fourth the new atheism is collapsing
shortly after 9/11 the so-called new
atheists made a powerful prediction if
they could just get millions of people
to leave Christianity and to become
atheists the world would become better
more enlightened more rational more
scientific well we've had more than two
decades of people becoming atheists and
how has the world improved how much
closer are we to that scientific Utopia
we were promised nothing not one word
that the new atheists predicted came
true in fact is it just me or did the
entire world suddenly seem to go
completely insane the moment millions of
people started becoming atheists the new
atheists have been exposed they had
nothing literally nothing to offer the
world apart from constantly screaming
Sky daddy Sky daddy Sky daddy Sky daddy
Sky daddy people have caught on to the
bankruptcy of the new atheism and the
movement has lost all
momentum fifth young people people are
waking up studies in both the UK and the
US have shown that the trajectory is
changing young people in the UK are
abandoning atheism atheism peaked among
people my age and older young people are
significantly less likely to identify as
atheists than their parents were as for
the US Pew research just released their
latest findings in a report titled
decline of Christianity in the US has
slowed may have leveled off after years
of stady decline the numbers have
started going up for the past few
years sixth people in the west have
realized that secularism just isn't
strong enough to protect the west from
what's coming at us we've got Marxism
wokeism Islam and the forces that want
to tear down Christianity and Western
Civilization seem to get along really
well with each other in spite of their
differences almost as if their real
purpose is to tear down Christianity and
Western
Civilization people are realizing what
they're up against and they know that
secularism isn't enough but you can see
not only from the waves I've mentioned
the Red Wave of radical
Marxism the rainbow wave of the radical
sexual
Revolution and the Black Wave of radical
islamism but you can also see how
secular liberalism itself
has
failed put all of this together and
Christians have an opportunity we've
never had before and will probably never
have again and trust me this is an
opportunity you want to pounce on
because it's not going to last at least
not as it is now why not well think
about it the young people who are B
abandoning atheism this doesn't mean
they're becoming Christians they're
turning to all kinds of things they're
open now they're exploring options
now but if you're not there to talk to
them someone else will be there to talk
to them in other words that young person
who's open to listening right now might
not be open to listening two years from
now and think about how some of the
various issues I mentioned are connected
here's an example many of the apostates
who left Islam became apostates because
of the new atheism they bought it and
they left Islam as the new atheism
collapses some of these apostates are
going to start returning to Islam
they're going to say we gave atheism a
try it didn't work at least in Islam I
still had my family I'm going
back so we have a temporary window and
we don't want to wait until it starts to
close what do we do few things one this
is a really good good time to make sure
you understand what you believe why you
believe it and how to share it what you
believe why you believe it and how to
share it what you believe why you
believe it how to share it 62% of young
people in the UK are willing to listen
to your case for Christianity if you've
got one do you have one if not this is a
really really good time to get one the
doors are wide open and don't make the
mistake of thinking that you have to
learn everything about everything or
that you have to learn to respond to
every possible objection before you
engage you don't you want to change the
world learn one argument learn one point
learn one verse and use it over and over
and over again there are enough people
in the world that you can spend your
entire life presenting one point to them
and never run out of people think about
a thousand Christians each mastering a
different point and spending their lives
making the point they
mastered those Christians will change
the world even though each of them
learns one point so learn something
learn it well and use it two there are
some arguments that are more effective
the more people there are who know about
them there are certain cases where it
would be very very helpful if millions
of people all learned the same same
argument at the top of this list would
be the Islamic dilemma if millions of
Christians all learned what the Quran
says about the Bible dawa would be done
ball game stick a fork in it so why
don't millions of people just learn it
and end the
daah pure laziness as far as I can tell
but this is not a time to be lazy make
it a goal for 2025 to learn the Islamic
dilemma this year we will provide you
with everything you need
stay
tuned three be relentless have you
noticed that the people who are
spreading dangerous lies are completely
Relentless have you noticed that they
just keep coming with lie after lie
after lie no matter how many times the
LIE is
exposed you need to be relentless too
this is beyond dday level significance
here four if you're able be sure to
support people who are doing things you
know need to get done
all the things that need to get done
there are people who've dedicated their
lives to doing them we're talking about
authors and you know about an awesome
book share that with people if we're
talking about content creators you can
share links to their content wherever
someone needs that content if people are
doing this full-time there's probably a
way to support them financially so they
can keep doing what they're doing we
live in awesome times for that most of
your your favorite content creators
probably have some crowdfunding option
where their fans all chip in a dollar or
$2 or $10 a month and it adds up to a
person or an entire team being fully
funded if I'm one of your favorite
content creators you can chip in for my
work on patreon there's a link in the
description box any help would be much
appreciated but if you're able support
someone who's doing something you know
needs to get done lots of awesome
content creators doing lots of awesome
work out
there ladies and gentlemen a few years
ago I pulled back quite a bit I didn't
say nearly as much as I'd been saying
for the decade before that but I felt
burnt out unfocused pretty low energy
which is weird because I'm normally
pretty aggressive and amped up so I
didn't make a ton of content ended up
doing other things studying other things
jumping around from topic to topic and
now as I'm looking back at everything
thing I've been doing for the past few
years I realize it's all been
preparation for right now every random
topic I got interested in for a few
months everything that seemed like a
distraction it was all a bunch of pieces
that just came together for right
now 2025 is going to be a year like no
other catch me in December as we recap
everything that happens between now and
then and try to tell me I was wrong I'm
saying it it today in advance before it
happens year like no
other now what are you doing staring at
me you've got work to do if you're still
not sure what to do don't worry I've got
some ideas more to follow
[Music]